da-da-da-da-da-da da-da-da-da-da-da you
could run faster you would get more
fired up you'll be able to do more
push-ups or let your step there don't
say you do it yeah but you will probably
a lot of dudes probably but the point is
you would for sure get energy from that
like a drug
yes that was a cup of coffee and go like
woah this coffee is good right you hear
that song yeah put up that video the
other day oh yeah that I reposted
vibrations and yeah if you look deep
into this topic of vibrations and
symbols that come out and like explain
what we're talking about the I posted it
on my Instagram I reposted it because
it's really fascinating this is black
Matt it's it seems like it's just a Matt
that's charged yet being vibrated let's
explain what's happening for the people
who just lists not gonna play this video
because they're probably taking down
it's got a lot of views there's lots of
different versions of this online it
says amazing amazing amazing resonance
experiment so they put some say as it's
and this is probably salt okay they put
some sort of powdered stuff sand or salt
onto a black mat that's charged and then
they send certain Hertz through this
ones 3835 Hertz and then it makes a
different patterns crazy on the look at
this 3975 like every time they changed
the Hertz it has a different paddle the
4049 look at this pattern so the spirits
are wait that's unbelievable but yeah
and these are also you can take these
numbers and these can also be notes
that's a dark roasty thing on a piano or
used to hearing or singing right so
these can also be recreated in other
ways and are probably happening right
and to us you know that's not like maybe
one of those earworm here like Victor
you're in the back your neck vibrate or
something like that what if a certain
Hertz just spelled you're like your
grandparents name well what's
interesting is that each one of them are
different geometric patterns there are
these beautiful patterns they're
gorgeous and as you change the Hertz the
patterns morph immediately yeah and but
the thing is they're kind of fractal
like not fractal
they seem to be what's the word equal on
both sides is that we're way that this
is what I'm looking for mmm parallel no
no I think you were you're on the right
topic if the numbers a little more round
like a round number these are not
specific hurts like if you do a specific
likes wins different than identical but
anyway both sides are exactly the same
and it's separate and this one they're
not it's not separated in a half it's
it's it's all like the circle is the
center it all goes out from there but
they're different every time but they're
all even like see it looks the only
thing that's keeping it from being
perfect is that they run out of sand and
it looks like the power is centered
around the center part where the wires
are connected to so that's the most
potent but silicon beautiful so that may
like thing if you think about that like
in a maybe if there's a certain Hertz
going through the air
like in space yeah then it would form
like a solar system one better the
feeling that you get from like Rocky
right the feeling that you get from that
saw that things go your body yes yeah it
could literally could be like a little
drug look think about why people like
music so much because that musician is
your drug deal yeah okay you hear like
some old Elton John like you're in your
car and Saturday night comes on your
[ __ ] goosebumps car if you haven't
heard that song in a long time and you
don't expect it yeah oh [ __ ] yeah Jesse
had a friend that one makes you want a
hat you know that's a good song - yeah
but five is good this was done with my
like I was staying with musical notes
Wow
on water we're looking at the thing it
says the cyma scope is that how you say
that SIA cym a scope uses a high
definition camera to monitor the effects
of an individual sounds particular
vibrations on purified water revealing
for the first time what piano notes look
like ah there are people out there so
much more than you and me oh yeah oh god
it's it's amazing that we're considered
the same thing you know as what smart
people just really smart people yeah I
have someone like Sean Carolyn the
physicist and
breakdown particle physics and [ __ ] to
you you like is it hard it doesn't even
get in yeah does it I can repeat what he
said yeah I don't the [ __ ] it means when
people start talking about quantum
quantum things in quantum theory and
quantum particles as danger dude I don't
get I don't trust that kind of stuff a
lot of it well how about you know what
superposition is it's the ultimate what
the [ __ ] or a particle can be in the
state of motion and be still at the same
time all right well good luck with that
good luck yeah this magic world that
you've created crazy scientists that I
don't understand yeah I would rather do
something more chill than that
what the [ __ ] something can see yeah
sign up like or go for a run or
something Oh being rather than study
that or rather than be that particle oh
rather than study that in bit yeah like
I just think but don't you want someone
to know because don't you benefit from
cellphones well what about the such few
people know that if they all wanted to
lie to us then they could they would
have to be conspiracy now you starting
to sound like some other people